they're doing they're actually doing it
can you believe it observation is rising
conclusion belief is not required glad
you work that out I had a hard time
explaining to some of my co-workers why
I didn't like the Battlefront beta it
was a shooter that wore the high-rez
skin of a Star Wars title but somehow
managed to completely miss the soul of
that beloved space Western lucky for me
a character driven narrative in Knights
of the Fallen Empire DLC for Star Wars
The Old Republic came along and reminded
me of what an epic Star Wars tale should
look like warning some spoilers ahead
fallen Empire understands that large
epic struggles involving clashes of
civilizations aren't relatable unless
it's personal and personality is what
this DLC has in spades a self-doubting
villain seeking approval check a
trash-talking HK 55 murder robot check
tough moral decisions romance derelict
spaceships smuggler havens clever
self-aware writing check check and a big
bag of checks
query how's the meat bag bickering
finally exhausted itself
one thing that hasn't changed in five
years and I doubt it ever will meet back
bickering agreement
you said it musta fallen Empire
consistently makes you care about its
characters big or small by following the
old creative writing adage that every
character should be a hero from their
own epic you will find this story in
line with other fantastic sci-fi such as
Mass Effect now I have to talk about how
I play Star Wars The Old Republic
because it may inform your purchasing
decision I find this MMO to be best
played as a single-player experience dev
stated in our session that this DLC is
Knights of the Old Republic inspired and
that suits me fine in fact I find the
MMO aspects to be immensely distracting
for example when other characters line
up in carnival ride fashioned to
initiate fetch quest pickups I've also
come to love the Mass Effect style of
combat that doesn't have the bulk of
your eyeball time spent staring at
cooldowns at the bottom of the screen
hotkey Kombat can be fairly dull and on
engaging so if you're coming to fallen
Empire for combat you better love
traditional MMO style fighting now I
personally will not be playing the DLC
after the campaign is over but therein
lies the rub because there'll be nine
episodic chapters released monthly after
the Star Wars movie drops at the end of
the day I think the story of fallen
Empire is fantastic and worth your time
whether you want to continue the MMO
once the campaign is done is entirely up
to you
Knights of the Fallen Empire is included
for subscribers so it's mostly players
engaged with the free-to-play model that
will have to make this decision great
character driven narrative is the main
draw here and I will always be a sucker
for that in the Star Wars universe
that wasn't quite so bad
you